diffusée aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
ce statut aux un jeu de rôle qui a l'air
assez ouf c'est parti regardez comme
c'est très joli alors c'est extrêmement
simple nom sympa ok il ya des statuts
pour moi j'ai aucune foutue des duels
sont mais je sais comment elles vont
venir nous nous mettre la fessée
finalement nous mettre le talent sur les
fesses avant 2h au plat et le but du jeu
ça va être de ramasser 8 truc
voilà aucune des jeux voilà ça c'est des
jeux made japonais a parlé avant même
d'avoir peur au quine des yeux voilà
c'est ça le truc et je crois que à
chaque fois qu'on va quitter des yeux
les statuts vont se rapprocher nous
jusqu'à finalement qu'elle soit collée à
notre visage je connais dans l'église
c'est là où vous allez me semble qu
after years bas ou sur les marges déjà
au [ __ ] c'est horrible alors pour mon
top stairs et puis on va rencontrer
finalement le mal qui va nous hanter
allume le générateur pour ouvrir les
portes ans c'est horrible jefri sont
pressés autour un generator aller ça
fait quoi ça a été un soleil c'est ça il
s'allume des lampes à la place ça vous
les portes way assez cassé le soleil se
couche c'est parfait l'eau va là-bas
pour note peugeot 208 là et on se barre
on va faire ça c'est un très bon plan
allez allez on redescend c'est reparti
pour un open c'est quoi ça et pas de
sons totalement ok ces trucs là qui vont
nous poursuivre mon avis aa à aa
djombo ah non je me suis fait enchaîner
je suis pas enchaîner la foi qui depuis
tient maintenant mais c'est violent quoi
ça commence direct le statut et c'est
jusqu'à quelques coups comme nous tous
les matins tu vois puis a été levé du
mauvais pied quoi fine keynes to run
generator alors pas celle terry
warehouse 0 sur 10 est un faux je trouve
des naissances ou je sais pas quoi
ce que je dois trouver ça clôt aux
excuses moi c'est bon ok il a marché
[ __ ] mais ça fait enfin j'en peux plus
y en a 10 à trouver mon gars mais
comment voulez-vous réussir on est bien
là et sont là bas plus tard qu'elle m'a
fait faire des tours de manière vraiment
circulaire se permettra poté nous sentir
en vie encore sais pas mais où sont les
bidons journée 15 mai c'est ce qu'on ne
lit les ont cachés à mort quoi les
vidéos et les ont enterrés dans les
statuts attendez là c'est quoi c'est
l'église qui à l'annoncé ça et la
bayanne statut ou annoncé mort je vais
pas à temps mais ils sont planqués mon
gars c'est scandaleux
je vois plus statut jésus larguer
complètement je crois aux as où tout là
mon gars est ce qu'ils les ont pas caché
derrière les arbres comme des gros gros
fourbe
là par exemple non mais c'est pas
possible je retourne à l'église d'agia
embellir problème à temps va par là mais
voilà il ya un petit chemin aussi attend
avec la carte et les immenses quoi
quelle arnaque à temps mais là on peut
passer en dessous languissant quoi oh
oui oh oui mais
monsieur mais non au [ __ ] non j'ai
déjà fait mourir au bonjour
ainsi on n'est jamais venu je crois et
l'aurait snuff dans nos mais attend et
c'est non mais c'est une blague quoi
c'est plus long que daniel sendrous quoi
ce jeu il faut trouver les 10 bidon que
ya dans les trois endroits différents
rayons des concours tient à château
d'ecouen vincent visdeloup en plus en
fait on perd ça peut marcher en pas
chasser et ramasser tout ce qu'on voit
on n'est pas malade il ya trois zones
avec des vidéos dans chaque zone coiffe
au que fais tu là mais bien je te prends
sous le bras ah ok en fait via un
générateur par endroits à temps mais
j'ai même pas les 10 j'ai pu la lui mais
quoique larnack mais je m'en bats les
steaks alors allez à bientôt
j'ai besoin que d'un bidon pour la lui
mais moi j'aime qu'un bidon gelard
d'affaires haut de trouverez le
générateur vous marrez très jamais au 1
million sur un banc du drain a été posé
là quoi on vient le kidnapper le pauvre
puissance et en collecter encore 5 j'en
ai rien à faire moi je veux le generator
il serait pas dans l'eau il n'aurait pas
fait ça non je vois pourquoi l'on
matière voilà sept les statuts qui me
manipule psychologiquement pour que
j'aille me noyer basse et le teil
générateur qui était un adolescent fait
finalement attendez on va les voir
j'espère je suis pas tombé nez à nez
avec un une [ __ ] statut ce serait le
pire truc que nous c'est bon non je peux
pas j'ai monté pour rien il faut que je
trouve deux gigas de plus il en faut 8
sur 10 ans fait pour pouvoir démarrer
leurs générateurs sûr mais ni status in
there were zhuhai begin
il manque deux bidons et j'arrête pas de
tourner en rond à 20 pouces sont les
baies dont pedro
pour aller à la warehouse est quoi la
warehouse ok donc ici le seul chemin en
fait c'est ça c'est là d'où on vient
donc c'est l'église mais à mon avis un
autre chemin qui va être de l'autre côté
en fait pour aller au parking finalement
ben voilà juste là veut faire de l'effet
attend mais pourquoi je vous parlais
réservoir de toutes ces bagnoles quoi
trouver tous les sens qu'il faut pour
allumer 22 générateur oas est le pire
endroit pour trouver des petits bidons
d'essence rouge à eau
je vais maurice et même me désigne une
crise cardiaque j'y arriverai jamais
laisser sa place en moi je panique jeu
je perds mes moyens je transpire jeu je
me sens mal oh oh oh non on ne dit pas
je recommande eu des pulsions
j'abandonne dessus annoncé bon bah là
les tâches direct bah y'en a voilà ça
qu'on veut là aussi au oui en fait
surtout seul étage aller ok donc en fait
il ya dix bidons par zone et il en faut
8 pour les moins générateurs
ce qui veut dire que la logiquement il
aurait 7 ici et ensuite vous allez
trouver les derniers au parc mais ici
j'ai échoué si de grosses arnaques ont
passé leur bac jeu il n'y a aucun bidon
il ya que des cartons totalement vide
monsieur trompait opus t'es moche tu es
plus moche on me laissait un bidon de
s'annoncer une poubelle
mais quelle idée de fou dès 2010
poubelles la de salle de bar annonce un
vrai bijou j'ai des trucs et faune et
des petites corbeilles de celles des 26
dans lesquels tu médicaux y en avait
injustement devez calculer des côtes au
visage et j'allais dire est ce qu'on va
enfin trouver un bidon dans cet endroit
mais on n'a pas je suis sûr qu'il en a
pas c'est un mensonge non non mais il
marche même quand je quitte pas des yeux
c'est espèce de petit salon la wii
le dernier nom au nom retombe à un seul
[ __ ] bidon il nous en manquait un
homme est le mec qui bloque juste
l'entrée quoi esprits pour un vigile est
là encore 2e il en reste notamment dans
le parc et où il aurait scarred encore
dans le parc faut que l'on trouve juste
2 à oui oui le dernier opus à ces
[ __ ] de statut pedobear qui compte
une meute une fois je les entends elles
font allez un dernier bisou un dernier
mais un petit je m'en fous un petit
bijou mais sa samba quoi une fiole oui
c'est ça la petite poubelle laquelle les
salles de bain ce que je vous dis c'est
chiant
voilà c'est pas possible c'est que ça
fait quatre pages fait tout le tour y
ait dans le cul des statuts le vide en
moi je voulais juste un bidon juste un
bidon justin bridou direction o o
on va faire le tour à et aucun problème
à direction le dernier générateur pour
terminer ce jeu d'horreur tac tac c'est
la seu c ou c ou c la yeah man au phoque
moine fait prendre l'autre escalier a eu
aucun problème
tu avais des frissons je me tire d'ici
pour toujours avec ma peau valour
regardent peut m'arrêter là liberty
[Musique]
fabious homéopathique dauphin quoi du
journaleux quoi je même une pistache
comme récompense j'aurais aimé quoi bon
aller chose qui a compté 2 sur ce tube
[ __ ] mais j'ai eu très peur parfois le
ratio c'est une minute de peur pour 20
minutes de marche à trouver du pain de
vie des patients de plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas mais la vidéo comme
d'habitude on se retrouve très bientôt
son statut dans une autre vidéo mais à
savoir regarder qu'à tout le monde ou
pis
[Musique]